[Music]
first thing that you do is smell it
saying you're going to cyrillic and then
I find out what does it do
on your tongue and then you can really
experience the whole body of the milk
[Music]
my name is Bosco and I'm the milk
sommelier 50% of your flavor experience
is created by smell my name is John
Luger and I'm a dairy farmer we're here
in the heart of the wine country which
is not typically known as dairy country
the main thing what I do is telling the
story of the rich diversity of milk just
we come to walseth that we caught Walter
now le balsam we call this world
Oh swirls way we're sure milk and wine
are both made from the living products
that the one is made by soil and the
plum and the other one is also made by
the soil and the plum but there's the
cow we - we all think milk is white but
only by seeing this - milk we see the
milk is not right I see a really big
difference in a way do you see it I
think that milk can be clearer so where
the cow lives in which landscape like
Sonoma County but also the farmer and
his vision and his dreams that's all
part of their work now I'm very proud of
what my parents did they started this
farm next year we'll be here for six
years we operate a 700 cal organic dairy
farm we produce two five thousand
gallons of milk a day
with that I also farm 55 acres of wine
grapes those of us that farm have a
tremendous responsibility
and that's what's so exciting and fun
for me to be part of that John what we
have here is your milk this is the
miracle focusing on that organic and we
have the full fat and with 2% this is
like all fresh sweet and then also
having a long updates normally I prefer
the full fat milk because fat is the
carrier of tea so I'm really surprised
I like 2% advance flavor that's that's
great the milk or the perfect farmer job
it is own identity and it's also
something that you can experience in the
product farming is really about balance
as a farmer you are selling in front of
an orchestra and try to make a really
good simply this is my first time being
in California and I now taste the milk
you really can experience the quality
this is good
[Music]